thank you okay okay thank you for coming
everybody
so this is a joint walk with uh sasha
bark that probably all of you know
and people ask me to give a little
example of this construction so i will
try to give that
in there if you have some time i will
talk also about some extensions
okay so i will we dive into the repair
problem to understand what we're trying
actually to solve and so we when and
try to understand it through red solomon
codes and understand what
are their limitations so if we look at
14 10 read someone called
uh this as far as i know this is what is
being used in
facebook so you they take take chunks of
data they generate extra four
and you're immune to any four failures
but what happens if you lose
one and you start to repair the lost
uh chunk and we know that you can do it
only by accessing 10 other chunks
not less than that so it requires 10
times more reads compared to the amounts
of data that you actually want to repair
you return symbols you actually want to
recover one
and then if large portion of the cluster
itself encode it it will saturate your
network so that's the problem
okay so uh
people came up with the notion of local
recoverable codes and what is
a a nkr lrc is the following it's a
code of dimension k it takes n uh
k blocks generate and blocks so k
you add extra n minus k and what is this
k
r parameter it says any block has a
recovering set of
r other blocks what does it mean you
lose block number two
there exists some are our blocks such
that if i read their value
i can recover symbol number two
so the first observation that r is
between one and k
why is that you have to read something
in order to recover your symbol so it's
that's list one
why is it at least at most k because i
can read k over symbols decode the
entire code word
and then i can recover also my last
symbol
okay so the first question to ask what
is the connection between the locality
and minimum distance
so this answer was actually answered
this question was answered by
these guys with microsoft research they
actually defined this notion of lrc
and they gave this bound the d is at
most this number
and the first observation is
the smaller the localities you have to
pay if you want smaller quality you have
to pay by failure resilience if you're
just
r you you have to pay somehow
and another observation that this is a
generalization of the singleton bound if
you plug in r equals to k
you get back the singleton bomb and this
is in fact actually a bound that
incorporates into incorporates also the
locality of the code and we say that the
code
is a lrc is optimal if it achieves the
boundary
with the quality as the best possible
distance
okay so one of the previous
constructions so the first
construction in 2012 by vijay
and his students and they gave a
construction with the following
parameters
uh the downside of the construction is
the restricted length the
n the length of the code is a function
of r and k
but the good side is the field side the
good side is the fifth
so the field size is more or less n and
then in
2013 then there were three constructions
so these are guys in ut austin microsoft
and then microsoft research and
downside the field size is very large
it's exponential
and but the parameters are very flexible
almost any nk
r so the i the question is can we
combine these two we have small field
size and also
a flexible set of parameters so let's
look what the easy cases
and see if we can solve this problem for
these cases
so this is the bound that we we know
and if we if we plug in r equals to k as
i said we get back the singleton bond
the question can we construct such an
optimal code that it shifts this bound
with equality
and has locality k so indeed we can
construct and read solomon code as a
locality k the worst possible locality
but it also achieves this bound with the
quality as the best distance
and the field size is order of n
now let's look at the other extreme case
when r equals to one
if you plug in r equals to one you get
the following bond and then you ask
yourself can i get the
optimal code that has locality one and
then and achieves this
bound with equality so the answer is
indeed yes
what do you do you take n over two comma
k read solomon code you get n over two
symbols and just replicate each symbol
so in total you have
n symbols each symbol has its
twin symbol so you have locality one and
the distance of the code is twice the
distance of the original code and this
is the distance of the original code so
you get twice the distance
so again we can construct for the this
extreme case for r equals to one
we can construct the code or field size
linear in
it so the question what happens in the
middle can we construct
a codes when r is between one and k
so what is the properties of our
construction it's optimal distance
flexible set of parameters the field
size is comparable to the
code's length and it's a natural
generalization of the
well known read someone called the
rhythm i put it in red is because rich
someone calls a widely used
inferior practice and we can actually
use
uh known results about which hormone
causing
their generalization in our construction
i will talk about it later
okay so what is the intuition behind the
lrc construction
so if we take a read solomon code
information vector
is actually defined to us a polynomial
what we usually do we
we can draw the graph of the polynomial
and we evaluate the polynomial at
certain points and points
and we get the evaluation vector and
this is what we store we forget about
the polynomial and we just restore these
dots now if i lose one
symbol what do i do i recall that
actually this evaluation came from
evaluating a polynomial of degree at
most
three therefore it is enough to reca
to read for our symbols
and recover the polynomial and after i
recap their point
the polynomial i can recover the last
symbol this is a
this is how we do decoding a local
decoding or in
in fact decoding for its own code the
problem is they look
at the how much we pay we need to read
four symbols and this is
in this case this is the dimension of
the code
which is not good for us it's too high
so how can we reduce
the locality oh so after we decode
we get the back the symbol so how can we
reduce the locality
if a genie came to us and told us that
our through our point that we are
looking
to recover its value passes a low degree
polynomial
through our point and through enough
points that we already evaluated that
so that now we're back in business
because
now it suffices only not to reconstruct
the original polynomial but
to reconstruct the low degree polynomial
so in this case the
low degree polynomial is just a linear
polynomial so if we read these two
values
we can reconstruct the line and then
after we
reconstructing the line we can recover
the lost point
so the idea is just to make sure that
all the time through any points that we
evaluate that
there exists a low degree polynomial
that passes through this point
and through other points that already
evaluated that
so what is the construction uh so what
are the ingredients
so the we start with the a1 till a n
over r plus one
disjoint subsets of the field f
well the size of each subset is a plus
one so you have
in total endpoints of the field
what is the second ingredient g is a
polynomial in the ring of polynomials
over that field
and what are the constraints from g what
do we want from gg
is the polynomial of degree r plus one
and we want g to be constant on each
subset a i
so if i evaluate g at the point alpha
and j the point beta
where alpha and beta are in the same set
a i so i want
g to be constant on it
assuming that i found this set of
subsets and this polynomial i can
construct a code
how do i construct a code so i take k
information symbols a i j well i
so i have two indices for the
information i goes from zero to r minus
one j
goes in this is in this set
and i define the following polynomial
i goes from zero to x to the to r minus
one x to the i and then i have
a second term and there is a reason why
i drew it in
green i painted in green so this is the
encoding polynomial
and after i define a polynomial i
evaluate that polynomial
at the points alpha one to alpha n where
alpha
are in the subsets that i picked
so the claim is that this is an optimal
llc
optimal code so a few remarks about the
field size
so the only constraint about the field
size more or less is just
that we have enough uh elements in our
finite field so
we need n distinct elements so
the field set has to be at least n but
this is more or less the only
uh constraint the second remark
if i put sorry
if i if i assign here r equals to k
if you plug in r equals to k this goes j
goes from zero
to zero so basically what you end up
with is a polynomial of degree at most k
minus one
what i'm saying is when r equals to k
this can this this construction boils
down to red solomon code
so as i promised this is a
generalization of rich solomon code
and so i want to show
the optimality so i'm claiming that this
is an optimal code
so why is that so first of all about the
distance
so if i calculate the degree of this
polynomial f
the degree of this polynomial f is at
most
r minus 1 plus this is the degree of the
of x to the i plus the degree of the
inner polynomial
so the degree of g is r plus 1
times k over r minus 1.
this is the i's degree of j here
so the degree of f is most this number
if you open the brackets you get
this this is equals to k plus k over r
minus two you're doing calculate so
our evaluating polynomial is degree of
most that so therefore it has
this many at most this many roots and
since
this is a linear coding and the minimal
weight equals minimum distance
so that so the the distance is at least
n minus k plus k over r
minus two and if we go back to the
singleton bound
we know we see that this this is exactly
the single
so so i just proved to you that this
code actually has best
distance the question is why does it
have
this promised locality so for that
a i will define the following polynomial
so f i will be the the green part
so it just goes from zero to k over r
minus one
a i j g to the j
x and
so after i define this polynomial so the
encoding polynomial
becomes the summation i goes from 0 to r
minus 1
f i of x x to the i
so we call this polynomial these
polynomials f i
the coefficient polynomials because they
act as the coefficient
to the term x i x to the i in the in the
polynomial
so what can we say about this polynomial
f i
we know that g is constant on the
subsets so also g
square is also a polynomial that is
constant on a subset
and actually any power of g is constant
on the subsets ai
so if you take a linear combination of
polynomials that are constant on subsets
of a
i of the subset capital a i mean and
you get also a polynomial that is
constant on this subset so basically
what i'm saying that f
all the f i's are polynomials that are
constant on the subsets f
i with this observation we can actually
prove the locality
so let's say that we want to recover a
symbol that was belong
to the set for alpha in the set a1
we want to recover f of alpha
this is what we want to recover
so we should write it okay
um so we define the following polynomial
delta of x equals
the summation i goes from 0 to r minus 1
f i of a1
x to the i so as i said
f i is constant on the set a one so this
this
notation makes sense so you just check
the value that f
f i gets on the subset a1
and now if i go i go to here
so what the there's this very easy clay
claim the following claim is very easy
to prove and
what is this claim so i'm saying for any
alpha
in the sets for any better in the set a
one
or any better in the set a one
f of beta equals delta of beta
so this f is the encoding polynomial and
that that of beta is defined there
why is it true this is very easy so what
is f of beta
this one equals to the summation i goes
from 0 to r minus 1
f i of beta
beta to the i but this equals to
the summation of f i a one
better to the i because beta x belongs
to a one
and then this equals to delta of beta
now if i want to
so i want to know the value of f of
alpha since
alpha is in a1 this one equals to
delta of alpha so actually i need to
know if i want to know this value
i need to actually evaluate delta at the
point alpha
so if someone tells me what is delta i'm
done
now delta is the polynomial of degree r
minus one
so i need to know only our points on
delta
and therefore i know i will be able to
know delta
and then after i know that i know the
value of what i'm looking for
um so what i'm what i'm doing is
so i'm i'm reading the values the
following values
i'm reading f of beta
which equals delta of beta
and we're better is in the set a of one
minus
alpha so all these symbols are available
to me
so this set so i'm actually getting our
evaluations of
delta our distinct point so
i can recover once i'm reading f of beta
it's actually reading i'm getting
evaluation of delta
at our distinct points and therefore i
can recover delta and then i can recover
my last
point questions
so let's look at an example
let's say i'm trying to construct 942
lrc over f 13.
so i need nine evaluation points so i
take the following sets
1 3 9
second sets a2 is
a 2 6 5 and the third set
is 4 12
and 10. and my g will be
x to x cube
so you can check it you can easily check
that g is actually constant on each
of these subsets so if you plug it into
the equation into the formula here
uh the encoding polynomial f of x
equals a zero plus
a one x plus a
two x cubed plus
a three x to the fourth as you can see
we are missing one monomials here we
don't have the x square
so assuming that the information symbol
is all the all ones vector so we plug it
into the
we get the following polynomial this is
the polynomial that we're encoding at
and we encode that this nine points one
three nine two six five
four twelve and ten we get the following
information vector
the following evaluation vector and
let's say we lose the vector
the the point f at the point one
what do we do how do we do local
recovery
so we define we know that this
decoding polynomial delta is of degree
at most r minus one
where r equals to two so the degree is
at most one
and we need two extra points so we read
the value
of f at the point 3 which equals
delta the point 3 which equals 8
and then we read the number point f of
the point 9 equal
equals delta the point 9 equals to 7. we
do this polynomial interpolation
we solve this equation and we get 2
delta equals 2x plus 2. we have value of
x at the point 1
which equals f of the point y which
equals
okay so um
if i want to compare this 942 lrc with
the
read solomon 948 solomon so we get the
following a
property so both chords can be defined
over field of size 13 even 9.
and the minimum distance for the rates
hormone code of course we cannot beat
that
it's six it's best possible but in here
we get
slightly less five but the gain
is in the locality here it's four and
here you reduce the locality
by half to two okay so
i'm just going back there uh you could
have the nine four i scored over
nine right yes
but five one but for this nrc you have
to have 13. i don't know
yes yes yes i can also have it for nine
uh okay uh
but you will have to okay okay you can
also use for nine but yeah
okay so let's talk about the ingredients
so we assume that we can find these
subsets and this
polynomial g that is constant on the
subset the question is how can we
find them so there is a very easy way to
do it
using fallout the following claim if h
is the subgroup of
the multiplicative group of the field or
the additive group of the field
then the annihilator polynomial of h
which is defined like this
is constant on the cost sets of the of
this subgroup
so the constant of subgroup of the the
sub would partition the our space
so this gives us the the subsets
that we are looking for so this is very
easy to prove zero on the
set not only constant all right no no
it's
zero it's on the on the sub group but
it's con it's constant
which is not zero on the other cost
so using this algebraic structure of the
field we can easily get
uh this these ingredients and going back
to your question we can use
subgroup f9 you could use subgroup of
size three
within the f9 so a little thing i
understand everything but there is uh
so you don't lose so you can evaluate on
every point
on the like for read solomon you could
evaluate on every point but
uh for lrcs you have to leave out you
might have to leave out a little number
of points right
you know what no if i use for example if
i use
a subgroup of the additive group i can
evaluate at all points of the field
okay okay um
let's talk about multiple recovering
sets so the next question is okay
now we i've shown you how to get one
recovering set let's say you want
several so how do you do that
so there's a few ways one way is to take
product code
but there's a different way which gives
you slightly
better parameters is the following so
our method gives you constructs that
subs
a subspace of polynomials that if you
evaluate
these polynomials these sets of
elements you get some type some locality
i want
so this is a large subspace that you we
have constructed
but using the same method you can also
find another subspace that has locality
r2
so if you look at the intersection if
you evaluate only the polynomials that
are in the intersection of these
subspaces
you get both properties you get
polynomials that gives you locality r1
and also r2
and you can get several recovering sets
this way
that's the idea and
i want to give an example and compare it
to replication so when
main advance admin advantage of
replication is high availability for
whole data
what is hot data data that's been
accessed frequently
and we want to construct lrc with high
availability with small
overhead how do we do it
so we give an example of a codes of
dimension six you get you add extra six
symbols you get in total twelve symbols
and you have eight symbols among these
twelve symbols as two recovering sets
these joints recovering sets one of size
two and one with size
three and so what is the encoding
polynomial
this is the encoding point i just i i
wrote it just to show you that this is
the structure of this panel there are
many monomers that are missing and the
structures
it's a little bit weird but this is what
comes up
okay so i want to compare this 12 6
lrc with the replication so in
replication three times replication it's
it's widely used so if you have six
symbols you replicate them three times
you get in total eight and eight
eighteen symbols
and i wrote here one and one because
each symbol
has its two twin symbols so it's there
it's recovering sets of
two disjoint recovering sets of size one
so the hover and in the replication
three times the replication is 200
you add extra uh 12 symbols in our
construction it's the gain is very clear
the only overhead is only 100
and let's look at the resiliency so this
code can tolerate any two disk failures
not more than that
and what's surprising that our code can
tolerate even more than that
free disk failures and if we look at the
availability of the information so here
each symbols can be read three times
free
simultaneously three times by three
different users
and in our construction you have the
original symbol
and if this is being used by our user
you can go to the recovering set
and recover the symbols and if this is
uh being used by every server a user you
can
go and read the three other symbols
recover your symbol
and and get your data so this
in a way mimics the high availability
for whole data
and but with a big gain with the
overhead and the
failure resiliency okay how much time
fine okay
so um let's say we want to build a
little bit more
uh greedy and we want to have
much smaller fields as compared to the
length
so there are uh natural ways or
extensions to do that
so we call this construction just
presented read someone type construction
for llc codes
so if we restrict the field size and
we're trying to increase the the length
of the code
this natural leads to a g code
and another way to get small field size
compared to the left is to restrict the
left construct the code using this
construction restrict the left and then
to look at subfield sub code so you're
just trying to decrease
the field size
so this leads naturally to subfit sub
code
so this is tuna two extensions that we
recently submitted to papers that we
submit to i30
uh that goes along these two ways yeah
two paths so um so i want to talk about
cyclical center subfield sub codes
so this is a junk work with sharia
goparato and rob calderbank
together with sasha
um so if we have a code that is lrc over
f q to the m over a large finite field
we can say something about its dual code
we know that the dual code contain code
word of weight
r plus one this gives us the locality
now
if we want to look at the restriction of
the code to a
smaller field and analyze the locality
of this code
we need to look at the dual code of that
code so the connect relation between c
dual
and residual of the restriction is well
known result
the thought is using the trace mapping
so this is how we analyzed our codes
using the trace mapping
and we could say something about um
the locality of this code sorry the
quality of disco
okay so i want to just maybe end with a
surprising observation
so when you look you contract the code
and you look at the subfield sub code
this distance does not decrease it many
times actually increase if you look at
the subfield subcode
and the same thing same same thing works
here
what i'm saying is with the locality so
if you have a code c
of a large finite field and you restrict
yourself to
to the smaller field fq clearly you have
the same locality so you throw out
vectors or code words you don't you
didn't ruin the locality
so of course this code is locality r but
what is surprising is that in many times
durability does not not only it does not
increase its many cases it's much less
so this is a for me in the beginning it
was kind of surprising when i saw it
and so i won't get into that but i will
just give an example
so this code 43 33 secret code
with this set of routes the locality is
14 and the the field is over
it is defined over the field 2 to the
12. so the
locality is 14 but if you restrict your
code to f2
you get the following code with the same
landform and dimension but the locality
reduces by half which is kind of
surprising
and we can say more about more than just
about the locality we can say something
how many recovering set you have and
so on and this is comes into the picture
to analyze these codes and the
restriction
we need to use uh some known results so
maybe give us
irreducible cyclic codes well if you
in if they if you if the distance
doesn't suffer and the dimension doesn't
go down
this means that the original code wasn't
on the bar on this mds
yeah yeah yeah right but no no why why
no
this is the complete i just picked the
complete uh secret this is one secret
atomic cost
so the dimension does not go down right
so distance actually soft i mean
distance remains the same but it's over
binary
okay and so but so the original code
should not have been on the
on this uh on this mds type bound right
no no this
i specifically picked a complete this is
a one complete secular topic
so you just take the closure of this
atomic cos and you just take this
you get the same it means the original
code is just copies of a binary code
with shifts right
that's what it means it's like the the
higher the field it's just 12 copies of
the same code
anyway let's continue um
i'll just how much time okay i'll just
end with this uh i won't say much about
that
uh this is a joint work also with search
vladius
and so we can constru generalize this
contract
construction similarly as a retirement
code
can be generalized to into gopa code
this can be generalized to aj codes
and the local recovery is done through
polynomial interpolation
and we can construct asymptotic good
codes
and that's it that's what i want to say
all right maybe one question well uh
mary
so there is about first of all there is
a bound on the distance that
that arya gave but you're talking about
constructions yes
do you know what what what is known
about
if you restrict yourself to binary case
what is known apparently lower bound
so much not much is known so uh we have
a paper about that
there is an upper bond and lower bond is
something like a bbc codes
i mean ability is
okay so by lower bound you mean
impossible
okay so that's uh upper bound here
because again so there is there is a
bound
so this is exactly
right right so if you knew that exactly
you could compute it exactly as well
so you'll see your construction isn't it
related to earlier
construction of like redundant residue
codes uh
so you can view it as a redundant
residue codes uh
it's it's in fact you can view it as
there took it off
i continue okay um
so we can view it as it's actually it's
uh we talked about in the paper it's
converted the chinese reminder theorem
exactly that yeah
but there's something some added you
need to pick the the point that you're
actually evaluating at there is
but yes
thank you